ils ont vécu un moment d'histoire
les élèves de la troisième période du
collège bourbon ont participé à la
cérémonie commémorant le centenaire de
la bataille de verdun pendant quatre
jours ils ont vécu sous les tentes à
verdun avec plus de 4000 jeunes français
et allemands dans la tente de la journée
du 29 mai point d'orgue de cette
célébration une chorégraphie signée
volker schlondorff montrant des jeunes
fauchés par la mort devant l'ossuaire de
douaumont une scénographie qui évoque
les milliers de mort de l'une des
batailles la plus sanglante de la
première guerre mondiale
une commémoration qui s'est tenue en
présence du président de la république
françois hollande et de la chancelière
allemande angela merkel les collégiens
ont eu la chance d'être choisi pour
représenter la réunion et la france à
cette journée du souvenir
mais leur présence ne t'ai rien du
hasard c'est le travail accompli en
amont par leur professeur
d'histoire-géographie qui a aidé à
écrire cette histoire nous avons proposé
un projet il ya deux ans nous allons
proposer un autre projet s'est assis sur
gallipoli l'application
dans la campagne éternelle et lorsque le
projet d'envoyer une classe à verdun a
été connue le comité local du centenaire
nous a sélectionné à sélectionner le
collège donc pour participer à ce voyage
donc
nous avons choisi de la classe de
troisième au perrier qui travaille sur
un autre projet sont gallipoli
stationnaire dogues qui étaient
impliqués pour le centenaire 4000 jeunes
qui se sont retrouvés autour d'un
programme pédagogique sur trois thèmes
majeurs comprendre la bataille de verdun
en 2009 116 comprendre la construction
de l'amitié franco-allemande et
promouvoir la citoyenneté la démocratie
et la paix le gros du travail a été au
début les changes entre les classes
franco-allemande en fait un échange de
rencontre pas encore un travail sur
l'histoire la premier 10 étaient des
répétitions pour là pour le spectacle le
samedi on a pu visiter en convergeant et
nous l'indiquions dès eu la chance de
faire encore un tour supplémentaire et
d'aller voir tous les sites historiques
on était quatre mille sur le site et
c'était enfin c'était instructif
lorsqu'on a appris beaucoup de choses et
que ben là bas c'était vraiment un grand
échange franco-allemand pour représenter
que maintenant 91 la guerre civile j'ai
créé des liens avec
des allemands on avec une allemand qui
s'appelle emilie carouge été choisi pour
participer dans une télévision et donc
on a parlé je lui ai montré les poilus
rayonner du lycée qui ont combattu à
verdun et pensons qu'ils sont morts une
expérience unique et enrichissante et
pour certains l'aventuré d'une vie qui
restera à tout jamais dans les mémoires
on était quand même si c'était c'est
nous les poilus et on était vraiment
dans des conditions n'a aussi une petite
sacoche
les sacoches que les soldats portés
quand il y quand il à dallas guerre et
on a pu voir par exemple des délais
fusil des soldats comment cet effet les
baïonnettes et où on a vu aussi dans
dans l'ossuaire plusieurs tombes de
soldats morts et inconnus français donc
je pense que ça c'était l'une des plus
grandes guerres destructrices qui est en
france vista pour autant émouvant aussi
parce que déjà eu c'est super groll
santonniers avait beaucoup ton oui je
crois que ça
la france autre moment très riche de ce
voyage le recueillement sur les tombes
des poilus réunionnais tombés pour la
france et dont les corps sont enterrés à
verdun on est allé voir les tombes à
l'ossuaire de douaumont on il y avait
les seize mille tombes des soldats et
parmi elles on a trouvé trois tombes des
soldats rien n'est à nous et on a déposé
notamment un petit bleu et sur leur ton
pour repris parce que le bus et leur ai
présenté les poilus et du coup on a vu
les tombes et on était resté devant pour
qu'ils reposent en paix enfin des croix
des noms et quelques visages pour se
souvenir de tous ces soldats réunionnais
qui n'ont jamais revu leur terre natale
parmi tous ceux dont le nom est inscrit
sur la plaque commémorative posée à
l'entrée du collège bourbon celui de
georges massino six élèves du lycée
leconte-de-lisle devenu le collège
bourbon sont restés là bas dans les
tranchées de verdun
ils sont 98 anciens élèves à avoir été
tué pendant la première guerre mondiale
au total ce sont 1698 tr min qui
périront au cours de la guerre 14 18